go watch all that they're showing and
what are we doing we are clearly
transforming the Oscars that's the rule
of copyright law other than your right
to be wrong but you're not well within
your right to break the law the laws on
our side more importantly the people of
the United States are on our side and
most importantly the funny is on our
side all right we're back okay but we're
not back on YouTube so do you watch we
have a little phone here on Instagram go
to the Facebook page I don't even know
my facebook pages steven crowder
official okay if you're on Instagram
right now we've actually put this I
don't know if we can go to a long shot
we have a makeshift ladder up here right
now bastard with a phone you have no
sound Instagram people who are an
Instagram right now go watch this trim
on Facebook we were hit with there you
go can you show that again and it's
still better producing the Oscars 40,000
people watching on YouTube our biggest
stream ever and mounting by the way that
was it with only one guest and then ABC
decided hit us with a copyright strike
brother here's something it's really
important just so you know you pieces of
the story just changed yep you look like
idiots this is the problem right now
they're talking about how things are
shifting with Romo and how things are
shifting with old media right hold on a
second guys let's keep that let's keep
the volume down there because I really
am pissed and I can't hear my I can't
hear myself because we can't play the
audio now so I'll here's you guys yes
and that's not your fault
that's the fault of ABC and YouTube we
can't play the stream for you we can't
commentate in the stream what is the
Oscars what are the Oscars this year
it's pure propaganda go watch Vice go
watch black Klansmen go watch all that
they're showing and what are we doing we
are clearly transforming the Oscars
that's the rule of copyright law okay
it's a are you doing direct parody if so
it's okay well obviously we know about
the no party consent states then its are
you Trent is this transformative enough
for this to constitute new art that's
how we won our legal case with Shia
LaBeouf's you will not divide us
livestream by the way make no mistake
we've never lost we're going to have a
half asian pitbull
so far up your disgust you pieces of you
want to push propaganda out there and
then try and hit us with the copyright
strike saying that we're somehow
stealing or lifting your content by the
way we have more content prepared for
this Oscars live so then you
paired all year dumb this is the problem
at one point you could silence people
like us but now people like us can watch
your propagandizing I don't even know if
that's a word and coma now
yeah I'm constant I get it it's line now
Facebook right now this entire story
just changed because you done messed up
you know you were going to hit the
channel with the hard strikes we
wouldn't be able to stream tonight guess
what we're streaming on Facebook they
might take us down enough then we're
coming after you that bigoli and we're
getting this up as a clip we'll have
different streams being by the way
everyone watching watch this stream on
Facebook and just turn on the Oscars on
your television so you can watch along
with us ABC Disney is it ABC disney i
think we could solve this the main
reason that we're getting more viewers
than you the main reason we're kicking
the [ __ ] out of your late-night host is
because we're more flexible we're
smarter than you and we actually create
better content we create content on this
show with one writer and now an
assistant writer Brautigan intends up
three writers effectively that required
27 for you to create The Daily Show with
Trevor Noah which hasn't been funny
accidentally just like Maya Rudolph on
your precious [ __ ] stream here's the
thing you can take us down I understand
it yes your what wasn't your right to be
wrong but you're not well within your
right to break the law right and right
now you're trying to silence people who
are making you out to look like the
fools that you are make no mistake this
has happened before they've tried to
silence us before it happened with
Facebook with the Gizmodo article they
trying to throttle our page in which
you're probably watching right now by
the way Instagram please go to the
Facebook page excellent place we can
stream right now it happened before with
copyright strikes on YouTube and they
try to make it so that we could not
stream and it's happening again we've
won every single time yeah the laws on
our side more importantly the people of
the United States are on our side and
most importantly the funny is on our
side
town made a mistake you for crying out
loud I don't want to do that by the way
I don't wanna have to do this I don't
want to be the Facebook rent we wanted
to have some jokes with we had Michael
Myers come out and make himself a man
happy okay this is not a serious stream
but make no mistake by the way people
who are watching this is why you join up
at monthly if you're watching the
Facebook live now this is what we have a
costume contest I think a lot of people
disconnect from how we make a living
okay
how are we able to hoppers been
responding well the Kimo by the way I
didn't want to talk about this before
because I didn't want to be going out
there using it for you guys to join my
club but guess what the only place I
make a living because of what you see
tonight what's up with YouTube yeah it's
my club is your support by supporting
the show $99 a year right now use
Crowder Oscars promo code isn't that a
great we're using your stream to give
our people a discount and continue to
eat away at your network we're like for
the Laura who's gotten bigger than the
shark this is so far beyond the realm of
trying to silence the little guy you
want to champion a little guy up here
was it only piece of black with rickets
yes right here we're the underdog right
here we're trying to create content for
people who care and everyone here makes
a living off of Michael this is why this
is so important a lot of people say oh
maybe I don't like Glenn Beck maybe I
don't like some other shows at the blaze
listen I understand that people have
differences of opinions when it comes to
all different on-air personalities
personally I get along great with Mark
Levin I get along with Glenn Beck okay I
love Gavin McGinnis right but here's the
deal if you're not supporting us here
you're supporting YouTube you're
supporting the people who silence us
through your silence yeah are we able to
take care of hopper well we're able to
pay for chemo because you guys join mug
club how is everyone here able to make a
living well it's because you people join
mug club how is everyone here able to
afford healthcare well it's because you
guys join mug club and these people want
you to disconnect right because you've
been so disconnected for so long from
the big Hollywood pictures it's
impersonal they they're they're
impersonal with us there's this
disassociation that's occurred with
people like us out there creating
content or people like PewDiePie they
think you know with a copyright strike
they'll go away they think that for some
reason we're not in the same industry
that they are even though we're getting
more viewers with
much less money so don't allow that to
affect you don't depersonalized don't
disassociate with what's actually going
on the only way we're able to do these
streams and tomorrow we'll be able to
get up and call our half-asian SMU
cannot a law grad who's on retainer Club
we're coming for you and we're coming
for all the marbles and by the way
that's not just rhetoric look at the
track record that we have here lieth
Crowder look at the law in the same year
we settled out of court with Facebook
beat Shia LaBeouf's best friend and the
Guardian or Daily Telegraph I don't wish
any Schumer as well this same stuff
happened when we did a review Amy
Schumer's Netflix special yeah obviously
they're just taking the stream and
running it out there for free
that's a copyright violation you're
simply stealing content you won't find a
court in the world who will say that
this was simply ripping the Oscars
without any transformative dummies like
what I think is gonna happen what you
think is gonna happen
we have August NBC assume we have more
subscribers here on YouTube than you do
to your night show yeah Meyers yeah and
we surely have more viewers than Trevor
Noah video it's 1 million viewers and by
the way I don't want to go out there and
talk about our numbers all the time
because the numbers Abin flow but if you
guys have a video that comes from a late
night show that hits half of our average
number it's a king event at your office
it was only on YouTube trending next to
the [ __ ] makeup tutorials for four
days and half a million the real
barnburner was it I can blow my nose and
we have more viewers than you and that's
not to be arrogant that's not to brag
about our numbers but it doesn't say how
out of touch you are you don't
understand I bet you said a lot more
carefully if it were Seth Meyers or if
it were Trevor Noah what you don't
understand is that this show has more
viewers and by the way a far more
engaged audience I don't want anyone
being talk'st don't go Doc's any
executives at ABC or Disney we don't
want that obviously rise above it but do
send in your letters of complaint and of
course do join mug club because we are
coming
for you make no mistake and we haven't
lost yet maybe you'll get it right this
time but I wouldn't bet money on it hey
there if you like this video subscribe
or click one of these videos playing in
a box you know what hit the notification
bail because subscriptions don't really
mean anything anymore
especially if you're not 18 or older at
the very least logged in to YouTube as a
teen or older
because sometimes people are 25 but they
don't know how to use the YouTube system
properly and then you never just take
the notification Bell or you hate
yourself